le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
à la réunion le chômage fait des ravages
notamment chez les jeunes où il atteint
les 60% pour lutter contre l'exclusion
des 18 25 ans le département a imaginé
un projet expérimental en 2011
l' académie des dalons comment
fonctionne cette structure quels en sont
les résultats
c'est ce que nous allons découvrir aux
côtés de josélito un ancien académicien
[Musique]
c'est d'un pas décidé que josélito 20
ans se rend au travail va lui originaire
de la saline-les-hauts le jeune homme
vient de décrocher son premier contrat
dans cette boîte de production
audiovisuelle donc là je suis en train
de monter une captation live que j'ai
fait avec ses films et les élèves aux
prestations
je suis à la phase montage a pris une
mauvaise la phase de validation 6 à
l'ail
[Musique]
pourtant il y a quelques mois encore le
saint polois ne connaissez rien aux
caméras
j'ai appris ça quand il filme amis
socialistes
l'année dernière en sorte de la can read
[Musique]
donc là où il ya la famille dalons le
sud du bnq à son cerveau je reviens
justement pour proposer mes compétences
que j'ai acquis cnra académique l'
académie des dalons
c'est un dispositif départemental créé
en 2011 pour l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle des jeunes réunionnais
le principe trois mois d'internât à
l'académie suivi de neuf mois de service
civique
quand quelqu'un n'a plus de repères il
peut s'adresser à l'académie des dalons
il sera accompagné sur une période en
internat où il aura à se retrouver et à
retrouver un cadre familial
encadrés par des éducateurs qui vont
prendre soin de lui mais en même temps
qu'ils vont aussi de l'accompagner sur
son projet bonjour nambo josélito
revient ici plusieurs fois par mois pour
l'équipe et claude calmer le directeur
de la structure
il fait partie de leur grande famille à
son arrivée dans l'établissement
josélito avait un diplôme en poche mais
peu d'espoir ce poste à l'école un
circuit dans cet épisode et après je
suis resté chez moi pour les autres deux
ans
[Musique]
vous souhaitiez il faut reprendre avec
le soutien de l'équipe il se recentrer
sur sa passion de toujours la photo se
trouve que monsieur magalas à l'homme
avec les gens en particulier en
photographie des compétences
il savait déjà faire du montage on a
tous des choses qu'ils avaient travaillé
individuellement et donc ici le passage
à l'académie ça lui a permis de
participer à des entreprises qui ont
permis de se faire la main de rencontrer
aussi un futur employeur
et c'est comme ça que les choses se sont
construites pense que s'il ya une
palette anémie j'aurais par moubarak aux
professionnels maintenant il faut
continuer la route
continuer tout en montrant la voie c'est
désormais son désir
aujourd'hui l'académie accueille cinq
nouveaux membres et à chaque nouvelle
arrivée c'est le même rituel
le rituel d'accueil c'est quoi c'est un
moment où on se retrouve pour se
souhaiter la bienvenue et puis pour
partager tout ce qu'on va faire ensemble
dans la semaine une phrase clef à
retenir qu'on arrive à l'académie les
dalons c'est ce qui a écrit ici sur le
blason c'est vivre et agir
josélito fait partie des volontaires
pour mener la cérémonie comme d'autres
l'ont fait pour lui
j'ai de l'émotion parce que les annonces
cela c'était moi donc voilà je dis ça me
fait chaud au coeur d'être la revois des
jeunes nouveau revenir l'académie ne
fait pas des anciens jets d'eau
l'exemple après la levée des drapeaux
le conseil des dalons de nos directeurs
l'occasion de faire un point
donc je rappelle l académie des dalons
ça s'adresse à des jeunes de 18 à 25 ans
prioritairement donc les personnes qu'on
accueille l académie des dalons sont des
personnes qui pour de multiples raisons
n'ont pas pu aller au bout de leur
parcours de formation
donc l'objectif c'est c'est vraiment
avec vous de faire un travail autour de
la réussite autour de la mise en
confiance et de l'identification des
ressources que chacun possède le but
pour ces cinq recrues se construire un
vrai projet de vie sociale et
professionnelle
pendant trois mois ils vont participer à
des activités culturelles sportives et
des missions diverses mais ils vont
aussi apprendre à vivre en communauté
comme josélito avant de remplacer mon
ancien chambre donc c'est là que j'ai
passé trois mois d'été
la vue sur l'école sur le terrain je
voyais mes camarades sous le kiosque ce
que je vaux 100 expérience déjà j'ai
appris à vivre en communauté
parce que je me marie jeanne a des
centaines de jeunes ont séjourné dans
ses chambres
la plupart en sont ressortis grandis
avec de nouveau un avenir à contempler
on est à l'accueil de la 13e promotion
donc on commence à voir un retour sur le
devenir des gens incontestablement ça ça
fonctionne on est autour de 60%
une assertion
josélito vient désormais gonflé ce
pourcentage
il a convaincu stéphane son actuel
employeur par sa motivation
je l étais présent il était volontaire
et puis c'était aussi un plan un exemple
pour nous parce que comme il partait de
très haut en bus il se met à quatre
heures du matin
c'est ce qui me marque le plus c'est lui
c'est que quelque part quand elle a un
objectif il va jusqu'au bout aujourd'hui
la rando chèque emploi vient et c'est
lui qui maintenant va passer le diplôme
de technicien d'une gêne et multimédia
un contrat un diplôme en préparation et
une passion dévoilé aujourd'hui le jeune
saint paul white à nouveau aux commandes
de sa vie en garde du fait ce que j'ai
aujourd'hui
en passant je vis mon travail je
conseille aux gens justement de postuler
à l'académie est motivé et de volonté
250 jeunes ont été accompagnés par
l'académie des talents avec ceux qui
sont sur le site de bernicat s'affolent
mais un deuxième site à la plaine des
cafres alors si vous êtes un jeune
si vous avez besoin de retrouver des
repères d'être accompagné n'hésitez pas
à dresser vie à l'académie des dames
[Musique]
l' académie des dalons est un dispositif
expérimental mis en place par le
département
objectif encourager l'intégration
sociale et professionnelle des jeunes de
18 à 25 ans ces jeunes signent avec le
département et l'académie un contrat
d'engagement d'un an qui comprend trois
mois d'internât et 9 mois de service
civique
l' académie des dalons compte deux sites
à la réunion le site du bernica à saint
paul accueille trois sessions par an
tout comme le site de la plaine des
cafres au tampon si vous aussi vous
voulez intégrer l'académie des dalons
vous pouvez consulter le site
www.cgi.com
slash dalons ou appeler au numéro vert 0
800 1 801 000
[Musique]